all the way down to New Orleans for me
always will always well what does this
night mean and what it could be in the
excitement of tonight it is that it's
our you know it's our highest honor and
it's exciting you know it's a long long
run so it's exciting to get to the end
it's exciting for it to be the biggest
of the biggest and it'll be exciting to
you know get back to work again you have
more jokes written for tonight you're
BAFTA speech was off the chain and I
think you know you got a few folks now
I'm going all I'm going all like downer
tonight it's my plan come on I know you
get him down get him down and angry and
what will this mean do you go home and
you hold the Oscar with the kids you run
around and you all get a touch of it I
don't think it's gonna go that way but I
don't know who knows I know who knows
what's gonna happen yeah and by the way
I also want to thank you for all that
plan B has done for black films and all
the films that you have put up there
it's been fantastic and you guys do you
keep that in your mind when you're
looking at the slate of films that you
guys have kind of pushed out there well
we keep in mind great stories and
stories that need to be told and stories
that are relevant for our time right now
and that's certainly been the case yeah
excited for tonight
[Music]